hello reject nation I'm Greg Alva I'm
John YouTube original this is uh
produced by people who co-wrote and
produced Deadpool in Zombieland VAX
don't know anything else about it pic of
Wayne Knight oh yes
which like Hollywood hero yes I don't
know if you guys have ever heard us say
this over at a patron we do TV show
reactions in queue days what yeah one of
our war tears one of our top ones is
whatever video you requested must
definitely cover and put up on the
youtubes usually it's a reaction today
is another one and this one comes from a
man named Eric horseman eric is a guy
we've shouted out before Eric is a very
friendly dude a vegan in Atlanta where
it's very hard to be vegan mind you it's
the south but I was in a message with
him today and he was saying that he's
planning on getting two tattoos in a
couple of weeks
well one being of a dog a puppy that he
lost I'm sorry oh and then the other one
being a logo of the real rejects what
for real I hope you do that and I hope
immediately you are followed within the
same amounts of regret I want to see two
reaction videos from you on one of game
are real rejects logo tattoo and the
other one going what if I do this I just
hope that you either put it on a butt
cheek or like a tram the [ __ ] stamp
area maybe oh yeah film can't with two
reels coming out you know and then real
and we just do our are on your nutsack
and yeah one on each side anyway wasted
enough time here videos for you buddy
who the F word is Wayne I don't know I
would like to find out though I have a
feeling this trailer will hint no I got
everything I got that look from Tom
Cruise in collateral right before he
gets out of Jamie Foxx yeah like this is
like one moan that's camera just gives
me this look
[Laughter]
[Music]
Brockton Brockton mass they have that
font on be funky calm this that
professional
[Music]
this is Wayne
I like Wayne like Dean Brockton hey oh
it's okay what are you doing wait guys
got good Oh
Oh No those you only short break my
window you [ __ ] oh gee it's me little
[ __ ] whoa ouch ouch ouch ouch
I'm routing
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
we got a watch we gotta watch the other
I think there's like two other teasers
on there hey yeah I want to see two
other seasons I mean that was
fascinating that was really interesting
and strange the cinematography did have
kind of that Deadpool lighting a little
bit oh yeah it's got that like edgy but
also quirky thing but just in a totally
different balance you know it's just
like guys drama or something yeah like a
drama with like a weird intrinsic energy
of a good comedy Vaughn
oh my god everything but yeah has this
like dark comedic vibe yeah animes like
it did make me go who the [ __ ] is way
yeah yeah it actually did have that
effective who is this guy cuz you keep
thinking okay well here's where he does
something badass oh here's where he hits
them oh they're beating him up but then
he's gonna go there and like mess all
them up [ __ ] your other window to guess
his ass handed to him and break some
windows as the bike gets broken walks
off like a I can't tell if that's the
most badass thing ever because he's just
so unfazed by literally everything that
happens like kick ass where he can't
feel much you know what we must go to
the most trusted website in the world
yes wikipedia la Commedia Wayne follows
15 you're supposed to be 15 cheese I
suppose a 25 year old actor looks
amazing for playing a 15 year old watch
me like Google Marc McKenna and he's
like oh he's 14 his age is not on here
but he is definitely not 15 whatever
let's get past it we should be used to
that by now
he sets out on a dirtbike we saw the
dirt bye dude there was a dirt bike what
was that there was a bike place a
bicycle maybe he gets a dirt bike after
they break the real bike got it there we
go with his new crush we didn't see a
crush del play by Chara Bravo whoo
is 21 in real life which she's probably
playing it in 11-year old to take back
the 1978 Pontiac trans-am it was stolen
from his father before he died
oh is the Pontiac trans-am inside that
garage maybe it's Wayne and del against
the world
here's my concern I am uniquely
intrigued by a clip that did not have
much going for it and it made me go who
is this guy
and I'm wondering will this who is Wayne
vibe resonate throughout the show and be
enough to hook me or do I learn
everything in the pilot and go alright
yeah that's our gonna hold me for 22 to
30 prolonged minutes like I do
appreciate when they put out scenes like
these especially ones that are so
strange I mean oh yeah I wouldn't call
this a trailer but as it played out a
lot differently than I expected and I
mean if it can sustain that atmosphere
you know where you're just constantly
going well what is he gonna do yeah yeah
yeah that could be super intriguing yeah
it looks like it's a hard-r comedy it's
register is an action comedy huh that's
cool that's cool I'm down for some
action comedy I mean other people
kicking Wayne's ass a lot and the comedy
never gonna fight them back but maybe
he'll destroy some more property look
guys if you made it this far we're just
gonna watch the other teaser alright
yeah which one should we go let's go
would Wayne takes matters into his own
hands
okay listen Blaine she's always gonna be
people doing a lot of stuff
but you gotta let the proper people
handle it
[Music]
righting wrongs all your life just don't
be like those they're kids
it's that dirtbike
[Music]
[Music]
all right I guess I'm intrigued the
other one made me go what and then this
one okay I got it
I appreciate that was cool yeah I was
like all right yeah he's kind of like a
vigilante of sorts yeah well I love just
the way that comes out of the
principal's mouths just like you can't
go around righting wrongs oh yeah I feel
like yeah there will probably be a
clever edge to the writing too it's kind
of got this like indie dramedy vibe with
action comedy to it just like smacked
across the face with a heavy metal
guitar for ki-young weird depressed love
with action comedy and you know I feel
like that is a lane that Netflix or
stupid I feel like that is a lament yeah
the DC streaming service is really off
to a great start
suck it Deadpool mr. Poole says the
sickest burn I've heard all year yeah
holy [ __ ] they said what he said back to
her that Deadpool was right I kind of
want to watch someone where he's got the
chainsaw whoa all right okay we made it
42nd we made it this far it's a whole
Wayne marathon rated this far
[Music]
Bishop's nice trick oh I know her whoa
[Music]
I have gone from what the hell is this -
I cannot wait so glad we have a used
cheerio so that we have a YouTube for
you but yeah I know
and they seems like they are also
turning around their programming because
when you to read first draft it was like
what is even on this yeah like even if
the advertising was decent for it it's
like nobody really cared and now it's
like more and more I'm like I want check
out some of those you do read stuff
Cobra Kai really blew the doors alright
guys well this looks badass
the girl even looks great we've talked
plenty about it in the long video I
think we can go long we're probably good
knowing us but we know you probably
clicked off by this point are you
excited for a Wade there's certain into
it much bigger delight than I
anticipated you you guys can subscribe
to the reject nation click notification
bells maybe we'll do reactions to it by
the time janti comes around I'd be
caught up on enough to do it and check
us on patreon where we got TV show
reactions bye bye